In the beginning, Jim was a small town player.
He's a very smart, disciplined man.
Take your shot.
But make it your best, cause I get up, I eat you.
Then, the next thing you know he's a damn kingpin.
You know why?
Because the FBI let it happen.
I grew up with Jimmy and his brother Billy, the senator.
And that is a bond that doesn't get broken.
Your brother is wading into some very dark waters.
Jimmy's business is Jimmy's business.
We all need friends.
Even Jimmy, even you.
Bulger's playing us, making a fool of the Bureau.
We're in too deep, and he knows it.
God help us.
How come no one has nailed Whitey Bulger?
He seems to be involved in every crime in the city and yet the Bureau keeps saying he's clean.
Well, what's Bulger done?
What's he done?
Everything.